last night in his first State of the
Union address the president delivered
what was perhaps the most robust defense
of American exceptionalism since Reagan
the state of our union is strong this in
fact is our new American moment you can
dream anything you can be anything and
together we can achieve absolutely
anything Wow
now my question is when we have this
precious gift Liberty that men and women
fought and died for over the centuries
think about our flag our country why
wouldn't everyone believe that it's all
worth protecting and preserving that our
traditions and the American people are
worth protecting my duty and the sacred
duty of every elected official in this
chamber is to defend Americans to
protect their safety their families
their communities and their right to the
American dream because Americans are
dreamers too oh now that last line
simple never Trump media right over the
edge she saw a divisive speech the wedge
issue of immigration the scare tactics
of ms-13 it was a speech delivered
almost from an alternate reality you
tell me it's supposed to respond like
this to the Great Dictator
I think the frame that they felt in the
room was one that inflames the cultural
divides only over at that other Gabel
network would defending Americans in
America be controversial now call me
crazy but I think most Americans love it
when their president stands up for them
is a cheerleader for them Trump look
past the desperate detractors and toward
true American heroes
the officer who adopted the child of a
woman on drugs families who suffered the
death of children at the hands of ms-13
and by the
we're gonna hear from one of those
families later on in the show and that
brave North Korean defector who escaped
to help others do the same the president
celebrated our anthem the military
families and faiths and of course the
creation of two million new jobs
employee bonuses not crumbs business
investment optimism all good stuff Trump
is making things demonstrative Lee
better and the Democrats are seething
because of that when they can't even
bear to acknowledge the good when they
can't even feign the appearance of being
happy at good news for American workers
and American business something is
really wrong it's gone totally off the
rails the Democrats I think have allowed
their personal hatred of Trump the man
to blind them to all the good that's
happening around them now look at the
CBS CBS snap poll taken right after the
president's big speech last night eight
and ten Americans who watched the State
of the Union felt that the president was
trying to unite the country two-thirds
said the speech made them feel proud and
a third said it made them feel safer but
check out the Democrat reaction today
the president's speech was a
disappointment and a missed opportunity
what offices would be the lowest point
in the president's speech last night was
when he says Americans dream too it was
dangerous what he said last night what
he is doing brings tears to the eyes of
the Statue of Liberty well I don't know
Nancy should talk about tears and the
Statue of Liberty because that's a
statue the reality here is that by
reflexively attacking Trump while
providing no actual policy alternatives
Democrats undercut and undermine the
public good they call themselves
progressives but when there is actual
progress they recoil now the left isn't
afraid that Trump is going
fail no way they're afraid that he will
succeed and they're afraid that he is
succeeding right now I was thinking
about this earlier today I think they're
happiest moment maybe since Roy Moore
lost that Senate bid in Alabama was when
the stock market fell by 400 points
yesterday they were probably hoping that
it would take another nosedive today and
that would be a permanent downturn if
America were a stock they'd be shorting
it the Democrats went from hope and
change to nope and strange the Democrats
are now officially post-american
they become the grievance industrial
complex maybe a hodgepodge of leftist
rage and hate with one goal in mind to
keep their voters angry and resentful
so when Trump issues a call like this
they become unhinged we can lift our
citizens from welfare to work from
dependence to independence and from
poverty to prosperity Democrats don't
want to hear that and they certainly
don't want you hearing it all things
considered and it's hard to say this but
I really actually believe this they want
us weak and poor because when you're
weak you need them and they think they
can sell you on big government and in
turn they have more power over your life
now let's face it the Democrats politics
of bitterness I think it's pretty much
out of gas and their post State of the
Union temper tantrums show us that
Democrats have become the worst
stereotype that they tried really hard
to foist on President Trump they're
angry unserious and hateful and that's
the angle